Speaker 1: And another thing that Trump might
need containment for is his recently announced
January six commemorative press conference
that he's going to be holding down in South
Florida this week.
Trump did, in fact, announce that he is going
to hold this big press conference, give a
big old speech.
On the anniversary of the Jan. six Capitol
riot.
This is going to be held at Mar a Lago, all
all of the major media outlets will most likely
be there, which I happen to think is a big
mistake.
I think the best way to handle this upcoming
speech is to totally ignore it and pretend
it doesn't exist.
Don't give him the air time.
Absolutely.
Do not make him feel important.
That is the best thing the media outlets could
do.
And the reason they should do this is because
we already know what kind of drivel he's going
to be spewing at us during this little press
conference or whatever it is you want to call
it.
And we know that because he basically gave
us his talking points in his announcement.
Here it is.
Why isn't the UN Select Committee of Highly
Partizan political hacks investigating the
cause of the Jan. six protest, which was the
rigged presidential election of 2020?
I will be having a news conference on January
6th at Mar a Lago to discuss all of these
points and more.
Until then, remember the insurrection took
place on November 3rd.
It was the completely unarmed protest of the
rigged election that took place on January
6th.
All right.
So we're going to hear some more election
lies.
Maybe he's got some new ones to throw out
there, I don't know.
You know, it'd be great to have a remix of
the greatest hits instead of him just going
out there and playing the same old songs that
we all know so well.
But the downplaying of the events that took
place on January 6th.
That's the real problem.
And of course, he's doing that, I believe,
because he's gearing up for a presidential
run and he wants these people back in his
corner.
And he may have already lost some of them
because we have had plenty of reports over
the past year.
They're mad.
They didn't get presidential pardons.
He's not helping pay their legal bills.
They're mad that he hasn't stuck up for them
more over this past year.
So this might be his way of trying to atone
for that.
Although with regards to presidential pardons,
you really missed your opportunity on that
one, buddy.
So I don't know how many of these people are
willing to come back to you.
I know most of them likely will, but some
of them clearly won't.
But the danger lies in what he's going to
say, because he's going to, as he tells us
here, try to claim that these people were
just peaceful protesters, they weren't armed,
they didn't deserve any of this.
Of course, you can bet we're going to hear
stuff about Ashli Babbitt.
And how she was murdered by police officers
and how these bloodthirsty cops just shot
her in cold blood.
And for the record, I do not think that Ashli
Babbitt should have been killed.
Absolutely not.
Yeah, it doesn't matter who the cops are killing,
I'm against it.
So I do think that Ashley Babbitt should still
be alive today.
So too, for the record, should the police
officers that were there?
Because that's the port these conservatives
always like to gloss over, they like to talk
about Ashli Babbitt.
But we got multiple cops.
Where's their concern for that?
Where's the Blue Lives Matter crowd on that
issue, right?
Nowhere to be found.
Radio silence from those individuals.
And one of the reasons I also believe that
Donald Trump is doing this is because he sees
the walls closing in over here.
With that select committee investigation or
is he hilariously called it the UN Select
Committee who burn?
No, that's that's childish.
I can take that to my seven year old, and
I promise you he could come back in five minutes
with 10 better insults for the committee if
he wanted to go that route.
But the committee is getting closer.
The committee is getting closer to Donald
Trump, the sentences that we're starting to
see handed down for these Capitol rioters
are getting longer.
They're getting more intense.
The judges this past summer were telling prosecutors,
You're being too lenient on these individuals.
You're letting them off for lesser charges.
We can get them on more and we should to prove
a point.
But most importantly, Trump knows that that
committee is getting closer to him personally.
So he feels the best path forward for him
is to go out there with this press conference
that again, the media should ignore, but they
won't.
He's going to go out there, he's going to
lie about what happened, he's going to downplay
it, he's going to attempt to rewrite history
a year after we all watched it unfold on our
TVs.
But he's not doing it to protect the rioters.
He's not doing it because he feels any kind
of sympathy towards these individuals.
He's doing it.
To make it seem like a lesser offense that
his office at least was attempting to overturn
the results of the 2020 election.
And of course, that's why we're going to get
mostly election lies out of him that day.
You know, he has kind of been amped up about
all of that recently.
And it is because his administration is being
exposed.
We're finding out things because of the select
committee that we likely would have not otherwise
known.
We would not have known about the text messages
with Mark Meadows.
We would not have known about the Fox News
host reaching out and panicking, Oh my God,
you got to do something about these people.
So all of that combined has culminated in
Donald Trump feeling the need to go out there
and rewrite history for all of us and to get
not just the history of January 6th, but the
history of the 2020 election.
We've had the audits, we've had the recounts,
we've had the signature verifications.
We have gone through every possible step of
the process and the fraud that we have found
almost all of it.
Rests in the hands of Republican voters.
Still, majority of Republicans believe the
2020 election was in fact stolen, so Trump
will never give up those talking points because
unfortunately, they've been pretty darn effective
with his Republican base on Farron Cousins.
And for David Pakman, we'll be right back.